let me briefly show you
a high-level overview about our
journey in the last couple of months
we called our development program for a
covet 19
vaccine project light speed because you
can't go
faster than light and this was what we
aimed for this journey started in
january this year and was devoted
to the development of a well-tolerated
and effective covit-19 vaccine
following the highest scientific and
ethical standards
this was a journey of 11 10 to 11 months
which started with engineering multiple
potential candidates vaccine candidates
of which several entered clinical
testing
phase one in april this year in july
we selected together with our partner
pfizer
one of those candidates the most
promising one for a large phase free
trial
and in november this year we could
report
that in this trial our vaccine has met
all primary efficacy endpoints
on the next slide you can see that
project lightspeed is in fact
a global concerted larger scale effort
our phase free trial has been conducted
in multiple countries in the u.s
argentina brazil germany south africa
and in turkey the phase 3
trial has reached the final end points
in mid november in addition to
that we have regular regulatory
submissions
on a rolling basis ongoing not only
in the eu but also additional countries
such as canada
and australia we have in addition
an application at the usfda
for emergency use authorization
of our vaccine in in the u.s
and we are awaiting decisions by the
fda mid of december
and this is also the time horizon in
which we
expect decisions of the ema
on our conditional marketing
authorization
application